quand ils ont annoncé le grand prix à la
fin quand comme info je l'attendais pas
du tout et c'était bien de marquer le
but de la coupe du monde en finale c'est
pour cette pièce les cavaliers mise en
scène avec anne bourgeois que
l'yvelinois eric bouvron a reçu le
molière 2007 du théâtre privé cela aux
si tu as besoin de l'import de moi je
suis là le seul espoir je pense parce
que c'est amener quelque chose différent
dans le monde du théâtre privé qui n'est
pas toujours le canapé et les têtes d
affiche
c'était vraiment une équipe qui mène une
histoire qu'un certain profondeur d'une
manière je pense assez original et
novateur qui en réalité n'est pas sinon
innovateur parce que je faisais toujours
ça depuis que j'étais en afrique de même
forme un père français et d'une mère
grecque
il met en egypte est pas son enfance en
afrique du sud
des expériences et une passion du voyage
qu'il transmet dans ses spectacles
l'afghanistan pour les cavaliers la
frais pour buchmann et africa ou encore
la mongolie dans marco polo quand je
fais des spectacles
je cherche pas qu'est ce que votre la
prochaine pièce j'ai besoin de vivre des
expériences humaines d'abord je dis
toujours le trésor
c'est l'autre
c'est ça que qui m'attire quand je vous
parle si tu commences à vous questionner
qui vous êtes d'où vous venez soudain
c'est vous qui devenez le trésor parce
que je vous découvre je vous devenez un
monde fantastique avec des histoires
avec ce que tu as vécu les hauts les bas
donc c'est sa onzième piocher mêlant les
arts les genres les styles il aime
traiter chaque sujet avec une dose
d'humour un humour qui décline avec
l'association rire 78 basée à
rocquencourt tout il est le directeur
artistique
trop d'horreurs sait comment manger trop
de sucre et un présent on peut plus trop
de réflexion en celui trop d'émotions
c'est insupportable donc vous voyez
c'est c'est de se balader entre toutes
ses états d'âme que ce qui nous fait
comme être humain pour l'animal et même
pour l'homme
la chose la plus importante dans la
sexuelle
c'est l'odeur